excuse me could the ugly untalented gays
please report to the principal's office
I guess that's you guys
hello principal Myers first of all I
want to say God shut up you know why
you're here I don't actually for
committing a crime against Jeff our
quarterback and the most good-looking
All-American red-blooded muscular man
this town has ever seen sir please look
in the mirror okay the homecoming game
with Huntington is nearly a month away
do you know how long we've been working
toward this yes it's everywhere 20 years
couldn't be clearer I think I can
explain I can explain Jeff is psychotic
and he tried to murder US ah sure you're
all victims and girls are always right
right yeah actually how come you can't
buck up and learn to protect yourselves
without running somebody over maybe it's
because we're small and he's giant so we
needed to use a little Machinery did you
ever think of that sir can we just
explanation
nobody said buy a gun just calm down
everybody you know what what I'm gonna
expel you both no no no you have to
understand that this was a
misunderstanding we were just practicing
four
for a self-defense Club
self-defense what is that uh I'd say
it's like a Fight Club
well you're getting yes yes uh yes a
Fight Club where we beat each other up
and no we don't yeah no we don't shut up
okay you know what I don't care I don't
care you're over it okay yeah you can
beat the out of each other while
you perform The Vagina Monologues just
stay in your lane until you're munching
Beaver at Wesleyan yes sir